صلاح اهلا بكم الى نشره الاخبار من
الجزيره نبداها من الضفه الغربيه المحتله
حيث اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه استشهاد
الشابين فؤاد عابد ومحمد حوسيه متاثرين
بجروحهما اصابته ما برصاصه قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في بلده كفردان غربيه جنين كما
افادت مصادره طبيه فلسطينيه باصابته عدد
اخر من الفلسطينيين وصفت جراحه احدهم
بالخطيره وذلك خلال عمليه عسكريه لقوات
الاحتلال في البلده والتي هدمت احد منازل
ذوي الشهيدين احمد وعبد الرحمن عابد منفدي
عمليه حاجز الجلمه التي ادت لمقتل ضابط
اسرائيلي في ايلول سبتمبر الماضي وافادت
ما صدره الفلسطينيه بان اكثر من 60 دوريه
واليه عسكريه اقتحمت البلده وحصرتها
افرادها استحال بنايات المرتفعه وقد
اندلعت اشتباكات مسلحه بين وقاومين
فلسطينيين وجنود الاحتلال وقد اعلنت كتائب
شهداء الاقصى الجناح العسكري لحركه الفتح
وكتيبه جنين التابعه لسرايا القدس الجناح
المسلح لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي ان مقاتليهم
تصدوا للقوات الاحتلال هذه المشاهدين صور
مباشره تاتينا همم من همم قريه كفردان في
جنين علم يبدو بان قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي هو في هذه الاثناء تهدم البيت
الثاني همم لعائله منفدي هجوم حاجز الجلمه
الذي وقع في سبتمبر ايلول الماضي وكانت قد
هدمت همم احد المنزلين قبل حوالي ساعه
ونصف ساعه من العام
اذا مثلما ذكرنا بدات هذه العمليه التي
تشنها قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي خلال
ساعات الصباح الاولى اكثر من 60
دوريه واليه عسكريه اسرائيليه اقتحمت
البلده من اجل تنفيذي
هدم منزلي ذوي شهيدا احمد وعبد الرحمن
عابد وهما همم منفذ عمليه حاجز الجلمه
التي ادت لمقتل ضابط اسرائيلي كان ذلك في
ايلول سبتمبر الماضي همم هذه العمليه ادت
الى استشهاديها شابين فؤاد عابد ومحمد
حسين اللذين تاثر بجروحهما اثراء اصابتهما
برصاص قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في البلده
كانت هناك كذلك همم حالات همم اصابه
لمواطنين الفلسطينيين احدها همم كان همم
كانت فحرج مثل ما ذكرت وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه وذكر همم مراسلنا ينضم الي
الان من رام الله مدير مكتبى الجزيره وليد
العمري ليطلع عنا على مزيد من التفاصيل
عما يحدث في قريه كفردان في ااا في جنين
بالضفه الغربيه مرحبا وليد التفاصيل
العامه 2023 بمزيد من الشهداء وتبدا
الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده اليمين
المتطرف ايضا عامها او اولى اعمالها بقتل
مزيدا من الفلسطينيين الشهيدان وكما
ذكرتهم محمد حوشيه وهو من اليمون قريه
مجاوره
والشهيد الثاني هو وفؤاد عابد وهو من قريه
همم كفردان ايضا قتل عندما اقتحمت قوات
كبيره من قوات الاحتلال العشرات الاليات
العسكريه قريه كفردان وقامت بسد منافذها
واحتل جنود الاحتلال اسطح المنازل قبل ان
يشرعوا في عمليه هدم منزليه عائلتين احمد
عابد وعبد الرحمن عابد احدهما هو ضابط في
الاستخبارات الفلسطينيه والاخر من مرتبات
الاجهزه الامنيه ولذلك كانها قد نصبات
كمينا لقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قرب حاجز
الجلمه شمالي مدينه جنين على الخط هتختار
وتمكن من قتل ضابط واصابه اخرين قبل ان
يستشهد قوات الاحتلال قامت به هدم منزلي
العائلتين بعد هذا الاشتياح الواسع للقريه
والذي جرى ايضا وسط حاله من الاشباك وحسب
وزاره الصحه وشهود العيان هناك سته جرحى
فلسطينيين اخرين من بينهم جريح في جراحه
توصف بانها خطيره هذا التطور والذي كان
متوقعا في الحقيقه وان جاء مستعجله من قبل
الحكومه الجديده الى انه يشير الى ان
السلطات او الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده
ماضيها بنفس السياسه التي كانت تمارسها
الحكومه السابقه والحكومات السابقه
الاسرائيليه العام الماضي عام 2022 سقط
فيه اعلى عدد من الشهداء الفلسطينيين منذ
عام
2004 وهو العام الذي يعتبر وكانه نهايه
انتفاضه همم الاقصى وكان
الجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قد قام بعمليات
قتل واسعه لالف فلسطينيين في الضفه
الغربيه بالاضافه للحرب التي شنها على همم
قطاع غزه واستفرد فيها بالجهاد الاسلامي
حيث استشهده هناك 52 لكن العدد الاجمالي
ارتفع الى اكثر من 240 شهيدا وعدد
الاعتقالات التي كانت خلال العام الماضي
ايضا نحو سبعه اهداف
الاسير الفلسطيني الليله الماضيه شهدت
ايضا حملات اعتقال كانت تركز همم في منطقه
جنين كذلك احد المعتقلين هو الشقيقه هذا
الشهداء وايضا احد المعتقلين في مخيم
الامعري هو شقيق الاسير الشهيد ناصر ابو
حميد
هذا يشير الى قوات الاحتلال الماضيه في
عملياتها وكما قلنا هدمت منزلي عائلتين
الشهيدين احمد وعبد الرحمن عابد الذين
نفذها الكمين ضد قوه الاسرائيليه فيروس
سبتمبر الماضي وقد استشهد الشابين محمد
حوشيه وفؤاد عابد ايضا خلال المواجهات
التي وقعت صباحا وفجر هذا اليوم في قريه
كفردان الواقعه غربي مدينه جنين احد
الشهيدين كما قلنا هو من قريه اليامون او
بلده اليامون القريبه والاخر من قريه
كفردان وهو من اقرباء الشهيدين احمد عبد
الرحمن عابد من الفداء الكمين قرب حاجز
الجلمه في سبتمبر ايرور الماضي شكرا جزيلا
لك وليد العمري
من رام الله